ten years after its original release
nintendo is bringing the legend of zelda
skyward sword to the nintendo switch
and like wind waker hd and twilight
princess hd before it it's safe to
assume there will be some differences
between the original and remastered
versions of skyward sword
what are those differences you might be
asking yourself well you've come to the
right place
in this video i'll be sharing 12 of the
biggest changes you can find in skyward
sword hd
and after that i'll list off some of the
smaller changes that can be found too
if you're interested in seeing more
content like this then consider
subscribing to gamespot
we'd appreciate it number one button
controls
let's get through the biggest and most
well-known change first skyward sword hd
now has button controls on top of the
motion controls from the original game
i won't go through every single little
change because there are a lot and i can
make an entire
video dedicated to that topic alone but
here are the major ones
the right stick is used to move the
sword and mimic the functionality of the
motion controls allowing you to move the
sword in every direction
however if you want to do a spin attack
with the button controls you need to
move the right stick
left then right then left again super
quickly
and if you want to do a fatal blow you
need to move the right stick up
then down then up again super quickly on
top of that
clicking in on the left stick while
walking or standing does a shield bash
and clicking in on the right stick
thrusts the sword forward and does a
stab
the a button which originally interacted
with things made link dash and put away
your sword has been split into the a and
b
buttons with a being interact and b
being dash and putting away your sword
it's also worth noting that if you're
dashing and then click in the left stick
you'll make link roll instead of doing a
shield bash the a button is also now
used to leap when climbing
however you still need to shake the
joy-con like the wii remote to do this
if you're playing with motion controls
instead of button controls and now when
you're controlling the loft wing of
button controls you only need to hit a
to gain altitude instead of shaking the
controller and the left stick controls
the loft wing instead of the pointer
also worth noting that when walking on a
tightrope with button controls you only
need to use the left stick to balance
link
and if you fall off you can click the
left stick in to jostle the rope to
knock off enemies or hazards
and on top of that the right stick is
used to swing on ropes
there are also all the items in the game
and as you might have guessed most of
these are now controlled with the right
stick and zr when playing with button
controls
the bow beetle bug net slingshot claw
shots
whip and gus bellows all work like this
and most of them have gyro controls
except for the whip and the beetle
although to clarify you can aim the
beetle with gyro but once you shoot it
you can only control it with the left
stick and no gyro
then once you unlock the harp that gets
assigned to the x button and you can
strum it with the right stick
the biggest item change though is the
bombs with motion controls you can throw
or roll the bombs with a throw or roll
motion
with the button controls you pull out a
bomb with zr then hold the right stick
up for throw or down for roll
then click zr again to do that action it
was a little hard to wrap my brain
around that at first but i got the hang
of it pretty quick
but there is one huge change that is so
significant i'm giving it its own
numbered section
number two camera controls the original
skyward sword did not have camera
controls because the wii didn't have a
second control stick
instead you can hit z on the wii
nunchuck to recenter the camera and that
functionality still exists if you hit zl
on the switch
however nintendo actually added full 360
camera controls to skyward sword hd
how did they do it well if you're
playing with motion controls all you
need to do is move the right stick
simple enough but how does it work with
the button controls
well if you hold the l button then move
the right stick you can use the camera
controls
this actually works extremely well in my
opinion and i'm very happy to see full
camera controls in skyward sword
it improved the experience a lot and i
think the right stick for the sword and
then holding l with the right stick to
move the camera is pretty clever
number three you can save to any slot in
most zelda games
including the original skyward sword
once you picked a save file at the
beginning
that became your save file every time
you saved it would go to that save file
and that was the end of that however in
skyward sword hd
nintendo changed it so every time you go
to a bird statue to save
you can choose which of the three slots
you want to save to granted
if you really wanted to you could
technically save then quit the game
then copy your file to another save slot
to preserve a specific spot in the game
but now it's much easier and more
streamlined
for example i stream skyward sword hd
here on gamespot
i knew i wanted to stream the skyview
temple so i saved over my main file then
made a separate save over a different
file that i'd used for the stream
then continued the game easy this also
helps for something else we'll talk
about a bit later
but for now you'll also notice there's a
fourth save slot
and what might that be number four
autosave
yes skyward sword hd has auto saves so
you don't have to worry about losing
save data or saving at a bird statue
every time you come across one
i'm not 100 sure just yet but after some
testing the auto saves seem to trigger
whenever you walk near a bird statue or
whenever you enter or leave a room or
area that requires a loading screen
you'll notice it in the bottom right
corner and it flashes so fast if you
blink you'll miss it
also a neat little detail is that it
cycles between the three sacred flames
from the game
if you're new to the game you probably
won't even notice that at first
the autosave does not overwrite your
manual saves as it exists as its own
save slot so you can't manipulate it
it's not revolutionary by any means but
it's a nice touch
something else that's interesting is
that in the original game there were
moments where after a lot of cutscenes
or after a dungeon
the game would ask you if you'd like to
save before moving on this has been
removed in skyward sword hd since the
auto saves exist
so i imagine speedrunners will be happy
about this and it just overall helps the
pacing of the game
number five names have been added to the
text boxes
in the original skyward sword the text
boxes just had the text
it never said which character was saying
that particular dialogue
well now in skyward sword hd the
developers have added the names of the
characters to the text boxes which is a
nice and welcome touch
how is it handled for characters that
haven't had their names revealed yet
well thankfully that isn't spoiled if
you're going in with no prior knowledge
take for example when you first meet
ghirahim in the skyview temple the text
boxes just say no
name until he reveals himself as lord
girohim and then every text box from
then on
says girohim when he's talking now you
might be saying to yourself
well who cares i was able to follow the
text just fine well
without this functionality how would you
know the guy sitting on the benches at
the bazaar are named
crew and dovos you wouldn't unless you
looked it up on the internet and i
firmly believe your life is better now
that you know that
number six the sheikah stone has been
removed oh how the times have changed
in the original skyward sword you'll
encounter shika stone after obtaining
the practice sword at the sparring hall
it tells you to come to it if you're
ever stuck in the game so what you can
do
is go back to this shika stone
throughout the game and it will give you
hints of what to do
basically just little videos that showed
you what to do to progress if you're
stuck
this was definitely a nintendo 2011 move
with this functionality also being an
ocarina of time 3d
it did make a comeback in majora's mask
3d in 2015 but was never used again in
another zelda game
and with that said in skyward sword hd
that sheikah stone is gone along with
all those video hints
after exiting the sparring hall you
could just continue your quest
no sheikah stone comes out to talk but
just to clarify
skyward sword also had gossip stones and
those are still in the game
once you receive the harp after
completing the third dungeon in the game
you'll be able to play it near flocks of
blessed butterflies and upon doing that
a gossip stone will pop out
say boingoing and drop a treasure on the
ground if you talk to the gossip stone
they'll give some advice in words but
not video examples like the sheikah
stone that got removed from this game
the patch of flowers where the shika
stone once resided is still there
and playing the harp unfortunately does
nothing rest well little guy
number 7 phi has been toned down a
little if you've read anything about
skyward sword on the internet then
you're probably aware that people are
not fond of the character phi
link's partner in skyward sword it
probably didn't help that phi came after
midna and twilight princess one of the
most beloved partners in the series but
that's not the point
phi would usually tell you very obvious
info and regurgitate things you may have
already seen in a cutscene or figured
out yourself
now of course phi was written as a
character whose sole purpose is to guide
the goddess's chosen hero
and if i were phi i'd also make sure
everything was blatantly obvious to make
sure link didn't screw up
but this is a video game and not a real
life situation and yes
phi has been toned down a little bit in
this game you can't exactly remove
phi entirely since their personality is
shaped in a very specific way and they
talk in a very specific way but the
developers did fix it a bit to let you
as the player figure things out more
a little more frequently so now in some
situations where fi would pop out
automatically in the original game
the sword will glow prompting you to
summon phi by hitting down on the d-pad
but you don't have to
the power is in your hands i won't list
off every situation for spoiler reasons
but here are a few instances where i
noticed fi didn't pop out automatically
like the original
the first situation is after you get
your shiny green outfit and head into
town
phi still tells you about how the column
of light that appeared created an
opening in the cloud barrier
and phi still recommends getting a
shield and potions before heading to the
surface
but in the original game phi also
mentions that you can change the
on-screen interface to remove stuff like
the giant wii remote in the hd remaster
fi doesn't mention this and you can
change the setting to simple from the
very beginning
the next situation that was removed is
before you dive into that green column
of light
five pops out to tell you that the green
pillar is a column of light that marks
the point where you can descend to the
surface
didn't phy just say that next up in the
original game
when you first encounter kiwi phi
mentions that your dowsing ability is
picking up the kikui as zelda despite
the kikui not being zelda and you should
follow the creature and investigate
guess it was kind of obvious that you
should follow the kikui running away
from you
and then when you use the slingshot to
bring down the vine to get into the deep
woods
phi would originally pop out to
basically explain to you what you just
did
and how to use the weapon you literally
just used the last one i'll mention is
right before the skyview temple
phi warns you that they detect zelda's
aura in the giant temple in front of you
and that there are numerous monsters
inside and asks if you want to proceed
and you actually have to say yes or no
if you say yes which i did of course
phi says not to be overconfident and if
you feel unprepared
you can return to the sky and get a
shield and potions you know
the same thing phi said earlier before
we even left the sky
in total i counted 17 situations where
phi's dialogue was changed or removed
entirely
if you want to know the others let me
know in the comments and i'd be happy to
write them out
or if you found some yourself then leave
those in the comments as well
it's possible that i missed some number
eight amiibo functionality
alongside the release of skyward sword
hd nintendo is releasing a zelda and
loftwing amiibo figure
the way the amiibo figure works is you
tap it when you're on the surface and
then you will immediately be transported
to the sky
instead of having to look for a bird
statue to do it then when you use the
amiibo again in the sky it'll return you
to the exact location where you tap the
amiibo on the surface
it even works in buildings and dungeons
unfortunately we did not have access to
the zelda and loftwing amiibo figure
before launch so i was not able to test
this functionality myself
you actually won't be able to use this
amiibo figure until after you've saved
gorko from the bokoblins and head to
farron woods for the first time
phi will pop out and let you know that
you can return to the sky and use the
amiibo to do it
amiibo are off by default in the
settings so you'll have to enable it
once phi mentions this
to use the amiibo hit down on the d-pad
to summon phi
and if you have amiibo enabled the
bottom left option will be to use amiibo
also yes i tried using a bunch of other
amiibo i own including the skyward sword
link amiibo and none of them work
fide just says the amiibo accessory is
one they can't recognize
oh well number nine increased frame rate
the legend of zelda skyward sword hd
runs at 60 frames per second making it a
much smoother experience overall
the original skyward sword on the other
hand only ran at 30 frames per second
skyward sword hd is also the second
zelda game to ever run at 60 frames per
second with the first being a link
between worlds on 3ds
i realize this section is kind of short
but the jump from 60fps to 30fps is a
big deal and i hope future zelda games
are also 60fps
number 10 fast forward dialogue in
skyward sword hd you can now hit the b
button to fast forward the dialogue
which was not an option in the original
game
this is great for replays or speed runs
as well as situations where you
accidentally engage with the character
again and are forced to read the same
dialogue
if you're playing this game for the
first time it might not be the biggest
deal in the world but it's a very nice
quality of life update that i'm glad
exists
number 11 streamlined item information
in the original skyward sword every time
you quit the game and then came back
all the same collectibles you'd gotten
before would re-explain themselves and
force you to not only read the text you
already read but wait as it would show
you the item count go up in your
inventory so either you left the system
on and never saved and quit
or you dealt with it hope you like
reading about how monster claws are
extremely sharp and look painful to even
touch for the millionth time
thankfully in skyward sword hd this was
removed just like how it was removed in
twilight princess hd
the first time you read the text is the
only time you read the text even if you
save and quit a bunch of times and i'd
argue we're all more thankful for it
however for the individual gratitude
crystals you can collect this has not
changed with the dialogue popup and item
count animation happening all 15 times
thankfully you can at least fast forward
the text this time i also want to note
that when you get an item from a chest
it will still explain itself again
but it won't show the item count going
up in your inventory so that's a little
better i guess
either way this is one of the better
changes for sure number 12
hero mode doesn't overwrite your save
files this last big change
may not seem significant for those
unaware but it actually makes a major
difference
let me explain in the original skyward
sword once you beat the game you'd
unlock hero mode
hero mode is a harder version of the
game where enemies do double damage and
there are no recovery hearts among other
things
so after watching the final cut scenes
the game would say you can play again in
hero mode using the save data do you
want to continue
and if you select yes it would hit you
with your progress up to this point will
be deleted
are you sure you want to play hero mode
uh
maybe not if you were unaware this was
about to happen you'd either have to
bite the bullet and delete your save so
this could overwrite it
or you'd have to copy your save file on
the title screen before the final boss
and then defeat the final boss on the
new file
and overwrite said file so you can keep
your original and the new hero mode save
since skyward sword hd allows you to
save on any save slot at any time
this situation has thankfully been fixed
and it'll allow you to pick the save
slot you want to put the new hero mode
save on
it'll still warn you that the progress
will be deleted but if you pick a new
save slot or overwrite an old one it'll
only delete that data and you can keep
your main save
remember earlier when i talked about how
being able to save to any slot is
helpful
this is the perfect example of that in
action so yes
there was a workaround in the original
version as i mentioned but only if you
knew to do it ahead of time
so in my mind this was a very meaningful
change that won't catch people off guard
once they finish the game
alright so those are all the bigger
changes now i'll quickly list off some
of the smaller ones i noticed
there's now an options button on the
title screen and on the gear screen that
lets you enable amiibo
change the screen display to simple
change the camera speed and invert the
vertical or horizontal camera controls
among other things
the quest logs on the title screen have
a new look with a photo added to each
otherwise it has all the same info as
the original game's quest logs they're
just in different places
the title cards at the beginning of the
game have been changed in the original
game it was just the zelda 25th
anniversary logo since this game was
released in november 2011 for the 25th
anniversary of zelda
in skyward sword hd it's white text on a
black background that says
nintendo presents the legend of zelda
skyward sword hd
it reminded me a lot of how breath of
the wild did a similar simplistic
approach with white text and a black
background
it's unfortunate we didn't get a new
35th anniversary logo to replace the
25th one from the original
some of the tutorial stuff in the
beginning has been toned down but it's
not entirely gone
one example is if you help fledge lift
the barrels in the original he'd explain
to you how you lift the barrels with a
and then set them down with a and how if
you held the wii remote up or down
you can throw or roll objects another
example is after horwell tells you that
you can dash up the boxes
he would then say not to dash too much
or you tire yourself out and run out of
stamina and he'd also tell you that you
can auto jump by just moving towards a
ledge like the one seen here
the dash up boxes part is still in hd
but all the other dialogue has been
removed
the last example i'll give is that you
can basically skip the entire sword
tutorial in the beginning
originally egas the sparring hall
instructor would scold you for just
sneaking out with the sword
and after learning about your loft wing
going missing would agree to let you
take it after you go through some sword
practice
now you don't have to actually do the
sword practice after the dash tutorial
with instructor horwell he'll ask you if
you can retrieve the headmaster's pet
mia from the roof
in the original game once you do that
horwell will just thank you
but in the hd version horwell gives you
a reward of 20 rupees
in the original game when you're looking
for your loft wing pippit will mark the
location of the waterfall on your map
because fledge overheard gruse and his
buddies say that they were planning to
hide link's loft wing near a waterfall
after pippit does this he asks link if
he knows how to use his map and hit the
plus button to access it
however in skyward sword hd the map
tutorial actually happens sooner with
the headmaster putting an x on your map
to show where the plaza is and telling
you that you can use the minus button to
access your map
in the original game you just had to
find the plaza yourself after the
headmaster mentions it
the design of the hearts in the upper
left corner has changed and shrunk and
the ruby display has been moved from the
top left to the bottom left of the
screen
the shield icon underneath the hearts
will glow every now and again when it
was just a static image in the original
game
the face icons on the map have changed
and in my opinion they look a lot
creepier
when flying your loft wing the giant b
button with the words slow down
underneath has been removed from the
on-screen display
the lighting inside the thunderhead has
changed and it's easier to see that it's
raining
the spirit vessel graphic has moved up
the screen ever so slightly
you can now skip cutscenes in the base
game by hitting minus this functionality
did exist in the original game but only
in hero mode
now it's available from the start and
lastly and this one is super minor
but the camera angles and camera
movements in the credits are mostly
different despite all the shots being in
the same locations
this is odd since every other cutscene
has the exact same camera angles
and on top of that the credits
themselves have been altered because the
hd version staff need to be added on top
of the original skyward sword staff
and that's it all the big and small
changes i noticed in the legend of zelda
skyward sword hd
anything i missed let me know down in
the comments below if you're interested
in more skyward sword hd videos we have
a bunch
including a graphics comparison between
the wii and switch versions our video
review written by kevin kenizevek
10 minutes of gameplay on our second
channel and a live stream i did with
kurt innovena
links to all of those can be found in
the description and for all things zelda
stay tuned to gamespot
[Music]
you